>> MALE: Introduce yourselves, you guys work
on GigaPan.
>> GIBSON: We do.
>> MALE: If you want to give us a little background
on what that site is and kind of what it does?
>> GIBSON: Sure, sure. We’ll I’m Rich
Gibson.
>> O'DONNELL: I’m Gabriel O'Donnell.
>> GIBSON: And we both work on the GigaPan
project. GigaPan project was originally a
product of CMU and NASA Ames. Going back in
time it originally came about were we needed
to stitch, Randy Sargent needed to stitch
the images that came from the Mars Exploration
Rovers, Spirit and Opportunity, and it gave
us an opportunity to see and care about Mars
in a way we never had before. So Randy had
this idea, if we care about Mars, so we can
explore images of it, what if we brought that
technology back to the Earth so we could care
about the Earth. So it became part of the
Global Connections Project and now we have
a robot imager that can take lots of pictures,
stitching software to stitch them together
and the website were people can upload, share,
explore, imitate amazing, brilliant gigapixel
imagery.
>> MALE: Sounds great, that sounds great.
And you got actually some fairly famous [INDISTINCT]
right now.
>> GIBSON: We do. We do, the most famous is
of the--the Obama inauguration, 30 million
people have seen it.
>> O'DONNELL: Something like it, yeah.
>> GIBSON: Yeah.
>> O'DONNELL: Probably, probably more, more
traffic than we ever expected to get within
the--within the first two weeks of that pano
going viral. More people had seen that GigaPan
and every other single GigaPan on our site
combined.
>> GIBSON: Yeah, it’s kind of amazing, and
it was his first GigaPan. After he took it,
he stitched it, he called--he said where do
I return this unit? Because it’s interesting
but I don’t think I’ll use it in my regular
photography. I think he has since changed
his mind.
>> MALE: So you guys were actually, also user
[INDISTINCT]?
>> GIBSON: Yes.
>> MALE: That’s right.
>> MALE: So how did that come about?
>> O'DONNELL: So, basically what we realize
is when the Obama pano went viral, our kind
of simply [INDISTINCT], it wasn’t sufficient
that we were, we were consuming--were consuming
way too much of the pipeline at CMU and he--we
really realized that we hadn't distributed--we
had distributed file system and it wasn’t
implemented I think the way we wanted to implement.
We didn’t have full confidence in the ideas
of backup and like ease of access and things
like that. So I actually don’t know who
initiated it, if it was you reaching out or
we reached out to you. But the end result
was that we started using app engine as our
[INDISTINCT]. We move the Obama panos over
and it was really spectacular. It--we went
from taking up, like, and this is at the point
were traffic had already decrease but it still
a lot, we went from like taking up 200 megabits
a second of CMU’s pipe to like, you know,
zero megabits per second because it was all
going on to the app engine, which, which led
to the funny thing, I think where, it was,
it was, I think it was maybe even unexpected
for you guys, maybe the amount of traffic
because I remember you guys saying, “Okay,
well, turn the switch.” And we turned the
switch and then two hours later it was like,
whoa.
>> MALE: Yup, and...
>> O'DONNELL: So app engine held up, I did--it
held up tremendously.
>> MALE: Yeah.
>> O'DONNELL: We--so one--as a developer,
one of the kind of--and this is, on the fringes
of the scenes, one of the kind of worries
we had was--you hear rumors about latency
and maybe they’re exaggerated, you know,
maybe they weren’t initially, we've had
no problems or whatsoever. And the thing,
the really thing that’s neat with the tile
touches for our panorama, is that you would
notice, you know, and you would notice pretty
quickly because you have big empty black spaces
in your panorama and we don’t see those.
>> MALE: That’s excellent. Excellent. So,
you moved over, did you experience any sort
of challenges moving over to using app engine
for...
>> O'DONNELL: So we’re still, I think we’re
still on the process actually of really optimizing
and figuring out exactly whether or not we’ve
made the correct optimizations. One of the,
one of the--kind of a hard challenges is,
we went from a system where we could really
rely on less [INDISTINCT] locality because
we’re serving from the file system to the
app engine where that, that’s really, not
really, it’s a different model to kind of
get your cut around. And so it’s--I think
it might be what happens if you are a serial
programmer and you’re beginning to--and
you’re beginning to write parallel code.
Like I suspected it’s actually like a similar
transition.
>> MALE: Okay, great. So, and you guys were
using the Python version of app engine?
>> O'DONNELL: That’s correct, yeah.
>> MALE: Okay, and you’re previously Python,
Python...?
>> MALE: Yes.
>> MALE: Okay, great. What are these--where
it kind of--what are the other aspects, how
has the app engine impacted, how you’ve
developed and anything like that, are you—have
you been working with it long enough that
is actually kind of changed your development
style?
>> O'DONNELL: It’s making us, it’s actually--previously
what we had, there’s two main developers,
David Holstius is probably, David Holstius
is probably the project lead in general. This
site was originally written in PHP and we
started moving to Django which is a Python-based
web ORM. And now that we’re moving to app
engine, so one of the things that--that’s
really nice about app engine is the ability
to actually download the environment right
on your desktop. Previously what we’re doing
is we would tab our own kind of shared SVN
repo and we check it out into separate little
websites. Which one--it's just two developers,
it’s okay because you can communicate as
if we've been adding developers to the group,
we’ve noticed [INDISTINCT] creeping in and
the actual ability then the like kind of full
down the app, to work on it locally, like
with our own set of things and then check
it back in using get--we’re actually using
get locally but checking it back up for when
we push the changes back at the app engine,
it’s been a lot easier.
>> MALE: Great. So if you had any advice to
somebody who was just coming to app engine,
what would it be like the one piece of advice
you want to hand over to them?
>> O'DONNELL: I would, I would look very strongly
in the--maybe object optimizations that--how
you need to rewrite your objects, how you--because
it’s not--chances are if you're coming from
a LAMP development environment, you’ve gotten
really good at optimizing for [INDISTINCT].
And that’s no longer an issue, and they’re
new--we’ve got new tricks and new tools
that you have to learn to use and you have
to learn to use them well. So that, that’s
probably where I recommend developers from
[INDISTINCT], like leading in to--especially
if they’re porting a legacy site to app
engine.
>> MALE: All right, that’s great. Well thanks
guys.
>> GIBSON: Thanks Gil.
>> MALE: Great having you here.
>> O'DONNELL: Thank you.